[Music]
about that Jurassic world fallen kingdom
has earned more than 300 million dollars
in the three weeks since it was released
probably a good indicator of the ongoing
fascination people have with dinosaurs
and now there may even be more species
to contemplate thanks to the work of
some globe-trotting scientists who made
a remarkable find in Mongolia's Gobi
Desert the mission was backed by the
Explorers Club and here to tell us all
about it as explorers club president and
the host of the PBS series born to
explore Richard we Richard good morning
good morning to you give me the
headlines first what did we find
well you know Mongolia it's quality
quantity and technology that's really
gonna rush her in a golden era of
paleontology so if you thought you like
dinosaurs from watching the Jurassic
Park thing over the next few years
you're just gonna see troves of new
discoveries you have new discoveries
already what have we what did you find
out there well you know they found in
addition to 250 new dig sites and that's
a pretty significant number they found
three new species of dinosaur hundreds
of bones and this was in a relatively
short period you see guys out there in
the Gobi Desert and unlike the movie
trailer
sometimes it's painstaking work with
little sort of butter knives and little
brushes yeah yeah but it's exciting but
you also use some new technology to kind
of get a handle on just where to do what
to look at and to me that's the exciting
part so you're taking NASA technology
stuff you're able to image large areas
of the earth and then they took consumer
drones they kit it out it's something
fancy called a enhance multi spectral
thermal imaging and that's a fancy way
of saying that you're seeing more colors
and variations in the soil they toggle
through some filters right there and
this would have taken scientists I mean
literally decades to go through that
kind of area the expedition was
supported by infinity motorcars and so
they're able to drive around with these
SUVs to areas where as Roy Chapman
Andrews
who first went in that area almost a
hundred years ago this was the real-life
Indiana Jones
he would have typically at that time
people took camels or horses he was the
first person take motorcars
so it's amazing in a hundred years how
far technology is gone and tell us a
little about bit about the new species
that were discovered well are they nalli
looking yeah you know some are you know
a lot of people familiar with the t-rex
a turbo source would have been the Asian
version of that and you know they found
a tooth from one of those that's about
five and a half inches long there's a
dinosaur egg you found as well yeah and
so you know think about this you've been
sitting in the sand or clay for 65 to 80
million years you're looking at the
tooth right there
but these eggs you know it was left
intact by some miracle and you see
embryonic material there and it all
increases our knowledge of how dinosaurs
came to inhabit the earth because we
don't really know what they look like
either there's this theory that perhaps
dinosaurs are closer to modern-day birds
with dramatic colorful feathers how
close are we to figuring out what they
really look like well it's funny you
mention that because we always do see a
Hollywood version of dinosaurs as a kid
you know the books were different than
now now I know that some dinosaurs had
feathers but if you look at a modern-day
rooster that if you took away the
feathers enlarged it that pretty much
looks like a t-rex so there are living
dinosaurs but you know this was an
exciting period because we still have
people coming out of the field in
Mongolia yet with a push of the button 7
billion people across the globe or
finding out information about this when
Darwin had his discovery Nicolai pocos
Islands it took him 10 years to write
about it another 10 years for critical
review a hundred years almost for people
to accept his theory and now we now to
not only have citizen science but we
have the marriage of Technology multi
national groups like the Mongolia hiding
stuff yeah I'm Simon if technology is
making everything fly back